im deutschen bundestag ging es gestern
endlich um ein thema das mir persönlich
in der öffentlichen debatte schon seit
jahren viel zu kurz kommt ja migration
meine damen und herren
unser bundestag hat mehrheitlich dem un
migrationspfad zugestimmt
und er hat in einem sogenannten
entschließungsantrag klargestellt dass
dieser pakt für deutschland rechtlich
nicht bindend ist
da steht zwar genauso schon in der
präambel des paktes aber heutzutage
kannst du gar nicht oft genug mit fakten
kommen denn es geht ja längst nicht mehr
um süßlichkeit das wissen sie es geht um
gefühlte wirklichkeit wissen sie was
hier bald los ist millionen wander
villiger afrikaner sitzen auf ihren
koffern
der pakt verheißen denen die soziale
hängematte und wir sollen sie aufspannen
ich muss sämtlichen afrikanern der
hängematte aufspannen
ich habe gerade mal 20 bäume im garten
wirklich
sie haben sich auch schon gefragt
deswegen stehen jetzt überall in
deutschland diese schilder hier
entstehen gratis wohnung für alle
afrikaner
natürlich ist der migrations packt so
wie er es nicht perfekt er unterscheidet
zum beispiel an manchen stellen nicht
genug zwischen legaler und illegaler
migration aber er ist wenigstens der
versuch ein globales problem wie
migration auch global anzugehen
tatsächlich an politik und medien die
also einfach mal emotionalität des
ganzen themas lange unterschätzt und
damit platz gelassen für profi
angstmacher der globale migrations packt
öffnet der millionenfachen einwanderung
aus afrika millionen einwanderer aus 192
millionen menschen 300 millionen 700
millionen werden angestiftet sich auf
den weg zu machen was natürlich
verschwörungstheorie aber ihr sollte das
wissen ja ich rede hier totalen
dünnschiss aber ihr solltet das wissen
freunde afd und co kriegen schon pickel
wahl in un migrations packt das wort
migration steckt es reicht schon
und ich habe mir solche leute beruhigt
sie natürlich nicht mit rechtlich nicht
bin
den fehler schon mal gemacht rechtlich
nicht bindend das ist falsch
sie wissen alle dass die seinerzeit
unverbindliche un
menschenrechtserklärung heute zwingendes
recht ist genau und wie viel leid und
schrecken haben diese verdammten
menschenrechte schon über den planeten
gebracht
denken sie da mal drüber nach weltweit
gibt es 250 millionen migranten menschen
auf der flucht menschen die von einem
land ins andere waren ob uns das gefällt
oder nicht und wenn wir an deren
situation in anderen ländern nichts
verbessern dann wiederholt sich 2015
kann eigentlich keiner wolle
außer einer partei die für ihren erfolg
auf ungeregelte einwanderung angewiesen
ist eine verschwörungstheorie aber das
sollten sie wissen meine damen und
herren
hier eine recht resolute spd frau
antwortet dem afd
menschenrechtsexperten und wissen sie
was ich gerade tue ich schäme mich fremd
dass wir hier über diesen lügen antrag
unsere zeit verschwenden ich schäme mich
dort von fremd haben sie das überhaupt
noch vernünftig durchgelesen ich am
liebsten höre ich jetzt noch was ganz
anderes sagen ja beschimpfen sie mich wo
ich das können wir auch gerne unter vier
augen machen
[Applaus]
die fdp hat so viel schiss gekriegt der
ist direkt nach afrika geflüchtet
richter eine hängematte glaube ich im
migrations pakt steht nichts von einem
recht auf migration wie die afg
behauptet überhaupt muss man vielleicht
noch mal klarstellen dass die wenigsten
menschen aus spaß flüchten und es wird
keine mutter und kein vater geben der in
einem lager irgendwo im libanon oder in
libyen ist und sagen wird wenn ich kein
trinkwasser habe keine
gesundheitsversorgung für mein kind ich
mag mich nicht auf dem weg nach
deutschland weil die haben den global
compact gar nicht unterschrieben
touché der un migrations pakt ist
geradezu ein schulbeispiel dafür wie die
rechten mittlerweile den diskurs bei uns
bestimmen und zwar bis weit ins
bürgerliche lager
jens spahn hat auch regelmäßig was von
zu viel politischer korrektheit und
friedrich merz stellt das deutsche
asylrecht in frage ohne zu merken dass
bei der anerkennung von flüchtlingen
schon seit jahren eu regeln gelten ja
als hätten sie den mann weiß nicht ende
der 90er eingefroren so kommt mir das
vor bei den wahlen in hessen und bayern
haben umfragen klar ergeben die bürger
in deutschland finden andere probleme
viel wichtiger trotzdem kommen wir
zwanghaft zurück auf migration immer das
ja schon pathologisch aber zum glück
heilbar
nicht nur frauen auch viele männer
leiden mindestens einmal im monat unter
akuten migrations schmerzen zu verlieren
komplex das interesse an allen anderen
außer migration leiden unter
schlafstörungen und schweren sparen
vorstellungen aber auch dafür gibt es
jetzt was von ratiopharm paranoia
zehnter mol mit der extra dosis
antibiotikum und neu für menschen die
geistig in den neunzigern stehen
geblieben sind merz spezial dragees
[Applaus]
pflege werde daher um der aufgeheizten
stimmung in sachen migrationspfad herr
zu werden muss der deutsche bundestag in
einem entschließungsantrag nochmal das
offensichtliche klar stellt so weit sind
wir schon
wir schalten live nach berlin zu unserem
reporter abdel karim in ein parlament
das überstunden macht und immer noch tag
tja und das wird jetzt auch eine weile
dauern hier
wenn du alle ängste und alle
wahnvorstellungen ernst nimmst hast du
halt ordentlich zu tun zum beispiel der
ewige afg vorwurf mit der heimlichen
umvolkung dazu der neue
entschließungsantrag der bundestag teilt
mit doktor angela merkel plant nichts
das deutsche volk gegen irgendein
anderes volk auszutauschen sie wüsste
auch gar nicht gegen welches höchstens
gegen die schweden gesehen einfach
besser aus als wir und das ist nur einer
von vielen entschließungsanträgen jetzt
zum beispiel der bundestag stellt fest
nach dem verzehr von kirchen kann man
problemlos baden geben
rothaarige haben keine zauberkräfte
elvis und hitler sind doch tot und ganz
wichtig masturbieren macht gar nicht
blind sondern höchstens kurzsichtig aber
wie gesagt ich dass er will ja und dann
gibt es doch auch meine lieblings af die
verschwörungstheorie wissen sie warum
die bundeswehr zu gehen die soldaten hat
nein aber die aif devices es fehlt
personal auch deswegen weil vor
jahrzehnten eine verheerende politische
entscheidung getroffen wurde
gilt doch die feststellung dass die
abtreibung als massenphänomen die
zukunft unseres volkes bedrohte
dazu stellt der deutsche bundestag fest
die situation der bundeswehr hat nichts
mit abtreibungen zu tun und die deutsche
armee verliert ihre weltkriege ohne
fremde hilfe
darauf sind wir stolz wäre das geklärt
ich finde man sollte den ganzen
verschwörungs quatsch einfach ignorieren
schwere fehler welche immer mehr
deutsche haben nunmal diffuse ängste zb
die panik dass jede echte teutone
irgendwann von einem menschen mit
migrationshintergrund ersetzt wird musst
du heutzutage alles ernst nehmen so ein
quatsch michael niemann abdel karim
[Applaus]
[Musik]